welcome back everybody september is
hunger action month and of course three
square food bank the sponsors of this
next segment is ready to help i spoke to
them about their nevada senior hunger
awareness campaign and how the community
can help
lisa welcome back
thank you so much for having me always
good to see you and update the community
on what three square is up to so let's
start with hunger action month
yes we are so excited september is
hunger action month and that's really
just an opportunity for us to stand
together as neighbors and people in our
community and advocate for those that
are hungry and don't have food
and to add to that of course the nevada
senior hunger campaign is still going on
so what's the update
well um it's been going a great meaning
that we have new people that are calling
in and getting services um that's how
people get uh hooked up into our
services as they call 702
765-4030 and we have kind caring
advocates that are standing by to help
you get on the right program for you do
you need golden groceries delivered once
a month do you want that curbside maybe
you need a lift ride to go to one of
those pantry locations we have over 30
of them in town
but we have a bunch of services they're
all free and they're available to those
that are 60 and older now let's discuss
those spinning trade-offs that our
seniors face on a daily basis
yeah we know that seniors in our
community at least once or twice a year
over 50 000 people
are having to make the hard decision
every month do i pay for food or do i
pay for my life saving medication or do
i pay for my food or do i pay for rent
this month you know and we know that
there are so many people in our
community struggling right now and we
don't want anyone having to make those
decisions and that's why our programs
are available they really help you
get the food that you need it's
nutritious food to help put money back
in your pocket so you can go buy those
medications i'm so glad that three
square is here for our seniors and
really just the entire community you
guys do so much for us so how can people
get involved with the action hunger
month and with the nevada senior hunger
campaign um great question so visit
threesquare.org and uh hunger action
month you can get involved in several
different ways but log online learn how
you can become a volunteer whether
that's on site or out in the community
at one of our emergency mobile
distributions right now you can make a
monetary gift or you can actually help
us run a virtual food drive how cool is
that that's great thank you so much lisa
we've got options to give back to our
community through three square we
appreciate you thank you
thank you three square foot bank for
sponsoring this segment you can visit
them on north pecos road for more
information call 702-765-4030
or just head to threesquare.org